you're at the top because you're willing
to in a general way of putting it behave
or be a certain way that other people
either can't yeah yeah right so you're
not going to be able to really from that
perspective you're definitely lonely at
the top there's no one that's going to
sit there and do what i'm willing to do
yeah to be there like where are you at i
don't know i haven't seen you but i'm
here by myself and i'm gonna keep
getting after it right that's kind of
the way yeah that's how people end up in
those positions yeah you don't end up in
those positions you don't get gifted
positions you don't just get end up i
shouldn't say never but i didn't had to
grind it out and keep grinding it out